all right so I take it after my review
last week you all did your homework and
played uncharted drake's Fortune
probably not but here's the review for
the second one uncharted 2 among thieves
alright so after my review the first
time charted it's safe to say you know I
like in charted drake's Fortune
uncharted 2 takes everything to the next
level in every way possible
so of course you play as Nathan Drake
again and this time you're looking for
what Marco Polo was looking for I guess
he started a journey with like 14 ships
and ended it with one so this games like
well what happened to the ships well
we'll explain history according to
Naughty Dog I don't even care probably
more accurate than what you've heard in
school and the gameplay is pretty much
the same as last time one dual handed
weapon one single handed weapon four
grenades you know what you need to kill
people but they did add some stuff like
you can pick up riot shields and use
them for cover you can pick up propane
tanks throw my guys and shoot them blow
up and you know people die and this time
there are a few more characters like
there just do that you team up with it
you don't trust him from the get-go and
there's a new love interest Chloe so
this kind of this love triangle between
Chloe Drake and Elena what I like about
the two chicks in this game is they're
different they're not like cookie cutter
like oh this one's like that one but
she's a brunette Chloe's like not a
survival look out for numero uno
yourself
Elena's like the tough chick from the
suburbs so you can pick either one
they're both hot don't even act like you
don't think so cuz they are I don't even
want to call this a game it's like a
cinematic experience that you play like
things happen in the game buildings fall
things get destroyed around you but
you're still playing while it's
happening most of the games would cut to
a cutscene to show it and this one's
like no if you're still in the driver's
seat just is dying around you there
are a couple scenes in this game one in
which you're in a building and a
helicopter is trying to kill you
something happens in that same it's like
one of the coolest things ever seen
happen in a game period it's that scene
that you want to save a safe spot right
before it happens so you can just go
back and play it I'm probably over
hyping it but when it happened I didn't
expect it to happen it was just awesome
and the way the game unfolds the plots
really cool too like the first scene in
the game is actually about halfway into
the game but you're just grab right from
it you're like how did this happen and
then after that you play the game from
the beginning of the story and see how
it all ended up like that I'm telling
you it's a playable cinematic experience
but I will say at a point you end up on
a moving train at that point the
difficulty level like skyrockets it's
like the games like alright yeah we've
had fun but now we're gonna kill you
and speaking of frustration there are a
couple enemies oh my god what I call the
bumble Rams because they look like the
bumble from Rudolph
Red Nosed Reindeer screw to ram and had
a kid and what I call grey Hulk with
AIDS because it looked like the gray
Incredible Hulk from The Incredible Hulk
but a lot skinnier so you know aids they
don't go down for you know that
scene in Star Trek first contact rep
ricard freaks out with the time he going
just oh just like waste that Borg he
could do that to one of these guys that
do it'll be like alright sweet yeah that
was fun sorry you wasted your clip now
I'm gonna beat your bald ass come here
those guys are frustrating when you run
into them you're like I hate this
right so the game's quite cool and it's
a lot longer than the first game to like
the first game before I reviewed it I
blew through it like a day I mean
granted it was like all day but a day in
the second one day one went by and I was
like I guess I got to finish it tomorrow
so what's a fair amount longer that's
awesome get your money's worth so the
first time charted drake's Fortune like
I said you should play it it's a good
game but uncharted 2 among thieves it's
like one of those games that you buy a
Playstation 3 for if you buy a
PlayStation 3 just to buy uncharted 2
among thieves no one's going to blame
you for that and below I put the opening
scene for uncharted 2 among thieves I'm
telling you you watch it how can you not
get hooked by it and I put the trailers
to uncharted 2 among thieves and
uncharted 3 drake's Deception below 2
cuz i think they're awesome i think you
should see them so one charted 2 among
thieves did you play it what did you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you